good morning can you breathe what's
going on
okay like this is
like i've never found out i've been
nominated for an emmy on live tv
it's like very embarrassing like
like i mean it's great it's awesome but
i'm just sort of like
i don't i feel like i need to get myself
together and like this just happened and
so i don't know like
let it out let it out let it out laverne
i got something to tell you
yes leslie what's up girl you were
nominated
for an emmy in
what category
best drama series no
that's actress gas actress
okay now i was supposed to do that way
smoothly
okay first of all laverne you just won
no you have a nominee girl you nominated
for guest actions on the child
yes wait what guess actress you've been
nominated
you've been nominated you've been
nominated
you've been nominated you've been
nominated
was it just that you were trying to
process what leslie was saying
was because we were all watching like
lose your mind this is amazing were you
just trying to process did you not
believe her
i'm still trying to process it i i i'm
like
i i'm like what what was i nominated for
like i'm like i only know what show
was it orange was it
like what was i nominated for like guest
actress and what like i really don't
know like it's just i'm so confused like
i'm really like
i'm like
listen i know it's probably so emotional
so crazy
so bananas but it's real and you deserve
it and we're also
very very proud of you now here's what
we got to look forward to now since you
were already nominee we gotta look
forward to the night
would you prefer for it to be a virtual
ceremony do you want to go
to a show like how would you feel
comfortable
being at a show in person i have no idea
i haven't even thought about like
i haven't thought about how they're
gonna do i mean how do you do a virtual
image
like i don't even know like if they're a
gown if they're a dress
like i'm sorry i i feel like i need to
be more articulate and have something
beautiful and
this is eloquent to say you don't you
don't this is a real moment
this happened to you on live tv i love
that we're like talking through this and
working through this i know
how excited you are i know what this
means to you can i just shout out
everybody at orange is the new black
genji cohen
um the entire cast and crew um i don't
know who else from the show was
nominated but i just was right last
season our fans the oranges new black
fans
are so incredible they have like they
still want to spin off they're still
like posting memes and
and videos and they love us so much and
it's just i'm so grateful
and so this i always share this with
every single um
one of my fellow actors from oranges new
black we are an ensemble we are a team
this is for all of us so shout out to
everybody of orange i love you so much
for our last season that that means a
lot thank you and we love you laverne
and i'm i'm very happy and proud of you
and i know this day just taking it i
know you haven't gotten a minute to but
let it sit
it's a good day it's a good day it's
another win okay a win
okay love you later